bueno el fin de la atención no pero
sigue raúl el comienzo de la distensión
tras el encuentro telefónico ambos
gobiernos de los países francia y eeuu
se emitieron un comunicado en el que
reconocen que si hubieran conversado
sobre temas estratégicos esto no se
habría producido por lo mismo acordaron
una ronda de consultas en profundidad
iniciarla dentro de lo posible ya que se
evitarían este tipo de problemas desde
el palacio del elíseo piensan eeuu
entendió ellos son los responsables de
este entredicho y que francia no busca
un hermano mayor en estados en eeuu sino
que un socio un partenaire y otros dicen
que esto también ha impulsado al
presidente macro o les sirve a él para
impulsar esta idea que tiene de un
proyecto europeo de defensa común ya que
a francia no le interesa unirse a esta
alianza autos